here's the thing so you are going back
into star wars world
there's a is it is it an obi-wan kenobi
spin-off or just a star wars spin-off
yeah it's um it's the obi-wan kenobi
story i suppose
okay yeah that's so it's you it's all
you
well it's not all me but it's but it's
it certainly
will be a lot of me which is good and uh
shirley's looking forward already
um we start shooting it in march next
year yeah can i ask you a question
yes please i love star wars i know
you're still a young man but you're
steadily getting closer
to alec guinness age in the original
stuff
do you feel you have to be like look a
bit more like he was in the first star
wars movies because you're
you're coming up on the outside track
and you're catching him up now
soon yes totally
i mean the the fun thing about doing
them in the first place when i was
much younger was trying to imagine alec
guinness
how would he play these scenes as a
younger guy and and it got
it led me to watch a lot of his early
work which i hadn't seen before
brilliant movies wonderful films that
he'd been in
and and i'd just had such a great time
sort of studying him
in those movies there was a great film
called the cards that i'd never seen
about a
dragon ball man who ends up being a sort
of mayor of a town or something
and so this time as you say frank i'm
much closer in age to him
and it will be it will be my challenge
to try and sort of
meet him somewhere you know i love alec
guinness i never got to meet him but i
love him through his work
and it's a great honor to be able to
sort of
try and try and pretend to be him a bit
younger you know
you